in the time in which he became famous in
1940 especially the supreme thing that
was needed was courage moral courage in
the council room
Churchill was very brave personally
brave on a battlefield repeatedly
Afghanistan the sedan Cuba South Africa
and he did stupendous things do you know
the Churchill wrote 50 books painted
more than 500 paintings and they're
pretty good won the Nobel Prize for
Literature saved the world we're going
to invite you to watch some lectures on
Winston Churchill I'm going to give them
Winston Churchill had a kind of strategy
about his whole life based on what he
thought about the times in which we live
and about the nature of human beings
these things are themes of his greatest
speeches at the high points of his
career including during the Second World
War he started writing about these
things even before he got into
Parliament before he was 25 years old I
think that Churchill is a statesman is
on a par with the very greatest in
history but Churchill lived in our time
and nobody else like him did and so we
don't really have among States but a
better teacher to help us figure out
this time than church
[Music]
you